we're on the homestretch and remember I
told you this is climbed at the actual
question Mike part 1 part 2 there the
pieces that we need to get to part 3 so
what do I do with this now just like
with this question we started with this
morning the main thing is not to not
that do we get the question it's like
where do I even begin how do I start
down this path so what should I have a
look at this carefully they're saying
sure that said one of them - the words
Finn you sleep ok does anyone want to
make a suggestion
okay so that's interesting so um what we
found what we're just taking advantage
of is that this is one half of the
factorization for some cubes is it
factorization so I guess you could write
that Z cubed plus a cube is what's that
Z plus a and then B Steve do you agree
with that so it's a record okay there's
sum of cubes is sort of playing around
in there okay
what could you do I really like that
this was notice actually did not notice
it at all so it's really helpful to
write something down and say it okay if
I use this as my starting point like if
I use this with my started right am I
likely to get anywhere that's successful
okay so if I have a look at this is this
going to be useful to me
now I actually think it would be in a
very roundabout way okay
think about this if I were to replace
that right
what I'm really solving for is this I
knew Zed cubed equals minus a cubed to
create that so what I'm finding is the
cube roots of that number whatever that
happens to be okay now I think that
would be like I'm going to get some use
out of that based on this right because
I should attempt to be solutions and
then you go you remember we drew the the
young circle we're gonna find them all
the way around I think that would work
however I think it is gonna be the long
way around I see something else and it's
okay if you like I didn't say that
immediately remember I told you part 1
and part 2
they try to give you a nudge in the
right direction okay so notice it did
what is there to they think that their
solution is to see what what's the
immediately previous thing we just
worked out
we just want that product of said what
is issue right now if that one is that
you really are the roots and this way
then we would call this the product of
roots right southern France roots
that's a to unity right again to see the
conventions okay now I can look at this
impertinent it's just for this thing
right I've got to poke their head I work
out the product of roots Joseph oblique
on a preventive routes this summer
Brutus is
vionnet's so that makes the product of
the roots see on a see see on a now
that's very promising that's good but
that's no guarantee that these are the
the right roots because they shouldn't
just satisfy the planted roots they
should also satisfy the Sun and they
they should do both yeah okay so what
should the son of Ruth be what should
have been okay
it should be - and you gotta be careful
because never use a in the questions
okay every - this on one do you read
that
so the summer grids should be minus that
coefficient
I'm just not calling it what it's called
because of the mix-up of letters on the
leading coefficient okay so I'm
expecting a how can I verify this
I've already verified that one we did
that in part two how do I verify this
one
where might where prepar to write what I
did was I knew what did she was I knew I
said what most well I've worked out what
said one was and then we just multiplied
them it's literally what we do so I
guess what I want to do is do the same
instead of multiplying I guess I'm gonna
Adam okay now you can see I've got here
he is z1 and he is now keep in mind
where I'm going I could um I could add
them in the form that they are at the
moment but there's something better I
can do I particularly want to look at
zip one right when you divide by a
complex number divided by a complex
number can you see I've gone from here
down do you get that he up down in other
words this is when I was trying to
imagine before I ever tainted cup choirs
instead of anti-clockwise right so
instead of multiplying by pile and three
pile of three to go in the opposite
direction what I haven't uh needs do to
go that way maybe negative pi/3 right
negative three so no it's instead of
multiplying by W move I've divided by W
but I can also say I'm multiplying by
the conjugate right do you remember that
this is a while ago dividing by a
complex number is the same as
multiplying by its conjugate so
therefore in this case this is the
conjugate right do you see that so do
you agree that's starting from a I could
get to z1 by multiplying by this guy
that will take me down in a clockwise
direction okay so I'm gonna write this
like that okay so these two I kind of
like different ways of looking at the
same thing by the way in case you're
looking for confirmation in case you're
looking for confirmation the reason I
can do this is because what happens to W
W bar when you multiply them together
does anyone remember yeah okay they're
exactly the cancel out by the way
they're going to exactly cancel out
because the modulus of Dalton is one
that's actually very important in case
you're cutting them well revisit that
point but it's just so you can see it's
for what now I'm ready to add these
things
okay so therefore z1 plus z2 equals this
Plus this now I'm expecting I'm
expecting that a whole bunch of W and W
bar things are going to cancel out right
victor gets it here yes so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
take out a factor of a because that's
supposed to be there so that's good that
leaves me with that dummy bar plus W how
am I going to turn that into one well
what can I do with these guys in order
to turn them into one well remember we
actually know what W is don't we we have
it in polar form right so if I just
replace W and W bar with their
equivalents in polar form then hopefully
I should get we get one Alice let's
cross our fingers let's give this a go
right I'm gonna leave WR percent and
come back to here W is just described so
I'm just gonna let that collars pile on
three
plus I'm sorry okay now how shall I
write w bar this is the the tweeters bit
okay I can write it like this a camera
like this and that'd be fine but
something better that will help me
simplify this faster is that this is
what a conjugate looks like in polar
form if I told you a conjugate in
rectangular form what would it be like
it's a key simpler isn't it it's X minus
iy okay so another way I could write it
is caused by 3 minus I sine hundred
that's really good because you can
cancel some stuff only right so I'm
gonna write that just squeezes it okay
so or is it we're on the home stretch
right as we just noticed you're gonna
get this guy and this guy they're gonna
cancel out right that leaves you with
two closed ply of 3 2 cos PI and 3 but I
know what closed palm tree is that's
plus 60 degrees which is 1/2
it had better be tough because this is
supposed to be 1 isn't it right so this
is a proof so I better not skip any
steps okay
right so how did you feel as you went
through that we had to draw on a lot of
knowledge from a lot of different places
we had to draw on like the conjugate
different ways of saying it and choosing
the way that made us get there quickest
if you didn't make this series of
decisions that I made you would still
get to the answer you'd probably just go
further around so practice will help you
get a sense of I should choose this form
rather than that form
I showed up right there conjugate like
this rather